how can you tell if your friends and the
people that you hang with are high or
low agency I had this essay I've never
published which is sofa friends versus
treadmill friends there's certain
friends that I hang around with
afterwards I need to lie on a sofa
because they kind of drain you of that
energy and then there's other friends
that we mean you know or you hang around
with them and you're like seven mile run
let's go we overclock our brains a big
thing that you'll see is energy
transference I always say that Steve
from Diary of a CEO who I used to work
at his company there was this thing
where I would walk in the office in the
morning and I'd open the door and bear
in mind Steve could be in the London
office Manchester office Berlin office
New York office he's constantly jet
setting around I could just see from
people's faces and how much energy was
in the room I got our Steve's hair today
without even seeing him when they enter
a room the energy just completely
changes I think that's often a
combination of high agency individuals